[Music]
on this sunday night
the china dilemma the plan put forward
by canada and its allies to counter
a massive chinese scheme and not anger
beijing a new government in israel after
12 years in office benjamin netanyahu
is now the opposition the vaccine
lottery alberta's inoculation
initiative to get it closer to reopening
plus
a diver's tale about being swallowed up
by a whale
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us china has long been asserting its
economic
influence over developing nations but
now canada and its allies are trying to
counter that by offering billions in
financing
to these countries on the final day of
the g7 summit
our prime minister insisted they had a
coordinated approach
dealing with beijing's ambitions but
there's sharp disagreement and it isn't
clear
how these world leaders contain the rise
of china
abigail beeman is covering the g7
meeting in britain
g7 leaders spent much time talking about
china but it doesn't seem as if they
could agree on what to do
you talk about action a specific action
that will be taken the communique was
not specific
on china what can you tell us about
action that that canada and that the g7
will take
a concrete example is the work that
we're going to be doing
on infrastructure investments in the
developing world
but the new plan to try and rival
china's massive global infrastructure
investments known as the belton road
initiative
is vague the one area where i think that
there probably was
a great deal of divergence was on
funding and material support for
the massive new infrastructure agreement
this sort of counter to the belton road
initiative that we don't see any
detail there i think speaks to that fact
building back greener
more consensus on climate leaders agreed
to reach net zero by 2050 and protect
30 percent of land and oceans by 2030.
canada pledged to double its climate
financing from 2015
to 5.3 billion dollars we had big pledge
from
uh from canada we've had big you know
big pledges for around the table
i i do think that we can uh we can get
there and
i think it's vital that we do and on
vaccines while the g7 leaders committed
to close to 1 billion doses for those in
need
the wh says the world needs 11 billion
doses we will also have more to say in
the coming weeks
as our vaccine procurement process
identifies even
more doses that can be shared with the
world after the more
intimate g7 summit here on the british
seaside the prime minister goes to
brussels for the nato summit it's a much
bigger table and a much
shorter summit meaning more pressure on
the prime minister to get face time with
those he feels are important to help
advance canada's interests
abigail beeman global news st dives
england
joe biden's work at the g7 is done but
the next league of his first foreign
tour
as president is just getting started on
monday
he meets with nato allies in brussels
where once again
biden will take aim at china he's trying
to take a hard-line approach but his
friends at nato
need to protect their own trade
interests with the communist government
here's jennifer johnson wrapping up the
final day of the g7 summit u.s president
joe biden was pleased the world leaders
joined together
in taking a hard line against china the
g7 explicitly agreed to call out human
rights abuses
in xinjiang and hong kong explicitly
and to take action against forced labor
in that country
in solar agriculture in the garment
industries because that's where it's
happening
and they've agreed we will do that china
hit back saying in a statement the days
when global decisions were dictated by a
small group of countries
are long gone
after a ceremonial visit to windsor
castle biden's next stop is brussels to
meet with nato allies
the u.s wants those leaders to dial up
pressure on china
but they may be more reluctant to
protect their own trade ties with
beijing
the u.s will also urge nato leaders to
increase their own military spending
a request often ignored but already
bringing out protesters
the us decides there will be a war then
europe will have to follow
and this is very detrimental for the
security
of europe ahead of his meeting with
russian president vladimir putin
president biden will ask nato leaders to
consider more economic sanctions against
russia
after cyber attacks have wreaked havoc
on several global companies
when we do them alone they tend to be
less effective than when we do them
in close collaboration with other
countries if russia chooses to continue
to act aggressively to act recklessly
we'll respond forcefully both sides
expect wednesday's summit to be much
less cordial
than putin's last meeting with president
donald trump in 2018.
jennifer johnson global news washington
benjamin netanyahu's historic 12-year
rule in israel is
over
[Applause]
the country's parliament narrowly voted
in favor of a new coalition government
during a raucous session today
a former ally of netanyahu naphtali
bennett is now prime minister
he will preside over a diverse and
fragile coalition made up of eight
parties with
deep ideological differences if just one
of them decides to leave the coalition
the government could collapse netanyahu
is now the opposition leader
but he's vowing to lead his party back
to power
today's vote ends a cycle of political
paralysis in
israel the country has held four
elections over the last
two years now to the global news
investigation into military misconduct
two senior military officers who went
golfing with canada's former top soldier
are under fire tonight vice chief of the
defense staff michael rouleaux and head
of the navy
vice admiral craig baines played with
general jonathan vance at ottawa's
highlands golf course
the optics aren't good because
technically rouleau has power over
military investigations and vance is
being investigated
for alleged sexual misconduct which he
denies
the prime minister was asked whether he
believes the two men should keep their
jobs
obviously the two men in question need
to answer those questions for themselves
but i know
that the minister of defense is
following up with the acting chief of
staff
on this issue in a statement a
spokesperson for the defense minister
called the latest developments
troubling and unacceptable a small
saskatchewan community is mourning the
death of an rcmp
officer killed in the line of duty
residents are laying flowers outside the
indian head rcmp detachment
constable shelby patton worked there for
over six years
yesterday the 26 year old was killed
when he pulled over a couple suspected
of stealing a vehicle
he was hit by the truck and died at the
scene a man and a woman
are in police custody alberta is
launching a province-wide lottery to
entice more people to get the covid 19
vaccine
the open for summer vaccine lottery will
offer
three one million dollar jackpots as
well as other unspecified prizes
the draw will be open to every albertan
aged 18 and older who gets vaccinated
the province's premier hopes the lottery
will encourage more people
to roll up their sleeves
please do your part because now a
vaccine shot
is also your shot at a million dollars
and you can help to keep yourself
your friends safe and help us all to get
back to normal
roughly 68 of eligible albertans have
received their first dose
the province hopes the lottery will push
that number past 70 percent
alberta is the second province to
introduce a vaccine lottery
manitoba launched a similar draw earlier
this month
canada's cruise industry has been
crippled by kova 19.
take the west coast normally it's a
major port for cruise ships coming from
alaska
right now international cruise ships are
banned in canadian waters
until february 2022 but if new proposed
legislation in the u.s gets passed
some ships may never return here's
global's richard zusman
it's an integral part of british
columbia's tourism economy
and now there are worries the cruise
industry dollars could be
floating away we do need to figure out a
way
to ensure that that act does not pass on
a permanent basis
that act is a bill now before the senate
from utah senator mike lee
it would make permanent a now temporary
change allowing cruise ships heading to
alaska
to bypass bc originally put forward for
pandemic reasons
i'm confident we're in a good place this
is a new wrinkle but
people want to come to british columbia
this was always our concern in the back
of our mind that when the waiver became
temporary there was always that
opportunity that it could become
permanent
and now that door has been kicked wide
open
in a typical summer there would likely
be two cruise ships
in this pier in victoria the industry
province-wide accounts for nearly three
billion dollars
and there's frustration that premier
horrigan didn't advocate
soon enough to stop this bill from
ending up in the senate
you really don't want to think about
what what it would look like without
crews in victoria or even in vancouver
for me to suggest that somehow i could
have thrown myself in front of this bus
and stopped it it's the height of hubris
in my mind cruising still
covered risky two guests aboard a major
cruise line in the caribbean
testing positive thursday and the
pandemic
is why it's currently banned to cruise
in canada until next year
a ban the industry hopes is made very
clear to the united states
will be lifted by next season we need
the premier
to to call upon the prime minister when
he returns
and say hey look you need to you need to
rescind this order
a call needed before the future of the
cruise industry
set sail in b.c richard zussman global
news
victoria it has been an exceptionally
warm and dry spring in parts of canada
and the united states
in the western u.s that's leading to
fears of severe water shortages
it's being dubbed a mega drought and as
jackson proskow explains
there's a risk things could go from bad
to worse
it's amazing to see it up close the
largest reservoir in the united states
is running on empty
lake mead behind iconic hoover dam is at
its lowest level in nearly 90 years down
to just
37 percent capacity this landscape
screams problems to me i mean just look
at the bathtub rings
to me that is an enormous wake-up call a
punishing drought has cut
water flows risking power production
from the dam
potentially triggering cuts downstream
on the colorado river
water that supplies arizona mexico
and california's lush agricultural lands
we have a fuel that is not planted
it has no water farmers are already
bracing for an economic disaster
and are leaving fields unplanted this
year we can't plan
because we don't know when we'll get
water that we
are trying to get for these crops
according to the u.s drought monitor
54 percent of the land in western states
is experiencing extreme or exceptional
drought
in california it's an astonishing 85
percent
a mega drought brought on by rising
temperatures due to climate change
coupled with growing demand tough
choices lie ahead
salmon now have to be trucked from
hatcheries to the sea
their natural spawning grounds have
dried out
on california's lake oroville houseboats
are being pulled out of the receding
water before it's too late
they're projecting by the end of summer
there will be no available ramps
no access they may have to move marinas
all over water utah's governor has
resorted to asking for divine
intervention
please join me and utahns regardless of
religious affiliation
in a weekend of humble prayer for rain
without substantial rain there's near
certainty of another explosive wildfire
season i'm nervous last year being the
worst fire season on record
this year is definitely shaping up to be
even worse there's also a sense that
this is all a preview of the new normal
in one of the fastest warming regions of
the united states
jackson prosko global news washington
coming up the boating frenzy why
canadians are taking to the water
as housing prices keep rising across
this country many canadians hoping to
settle down
are feeling burned by the high costs but
for those who don't feel like sticking
to one spot
there is a more affordable option out
there that's growing popular
and it's out in the open water here's
ann gaviola
jennifer golden and her partner chris
arnold are leaving the 3 500 square foot
house they rent in kitchener ontario to
live on a 38-foot boat they purchased
two weeks ago in penitentiary
if you're looking at the price of you
know renting home or taking on a
mortgage
right now with crazy housing prizes and
then you look at the
marina fees for an entire season
like it's crazy it's it was such an easy
decision
it started as a joke a month ago and now
it's become their next adventure
the couple their cats dogs and kids will
be living on the water on board this
cruiser yacht
we could totally live on a boat it's
like an rv but it's
bigger the toughest part of this
transition so far figuring out how to
stay connected
wi-fi at the marina is spotty both were
forced to work remotely during the
pandemic and they're confident they can
continue
both of us are involved with a lot of
zoom calls and
constantly and we've we've tried
some of those calls already on the boat
and have been pretty successful there
the family's purchase is part of a
booming trend canadian safe boating
council is seeing a boating frenzy from
coast to coast
we're expecting the same thing to happen
as was the case in 2020
with an explosion of boaters with people
not being able to travel they're looking
at alternate
means of recreation for themselves and
their families
16 million boaters and counting are
expected to take to the water from bc to
newfoundland
many picked up the hobby during the
pandemic transport canada issued twice
as many licenses for recreational votes
last month
as it did in may of 2020. the april
numbers were about triple what they were
in april 2020. golden and arnold are
among this year's crop of new boat
aficionados
they're now taking lessons to learn how
to handle their 33 year old vessel
we don't have rose colored glasses we
know that this is crazy
and we kind of
and we love that about it right so we
will just roll with the punches
they'll also be winterizing their
cottage which is where they'll spend the
colder months
if we decide that boating isn't our
thing we could end up just saying let's
just
stay at the cottage now because there's
no rules
yeah ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead the monumental task to honor
those who served with canada's
longest military mission
[Music]
[Applause]
a frantic rescue mission is underway in
central china where a huge gas explosion
leveled a building
killing at least 12 people the blast
happened in the morning in a residential
neighborhood near a food market
where people were having breakfast and
buying groceries at the time
at least 37 people are in critical
condition
canada's mission in afghanistan was this
country's longest military engagement
it began in 2001 and lasted 13 years
tens of thousands of troops served there
and 165 canadian lives were lost
now plans for a permanent monument to
honor them have been boiled down
to five final submissions and as ross
lord explains
deciding how to pay our respects is no
simple task
the war in afghanistan was canada's
first significant combat mission in a
half century
more than 40 thousand armed forces
members and hundreds of other canadians
took part
big numbers uh longest
military engagement and
no monument yet but that being said you
have to keep in mind that it takes time
to get the monuments going
a group of five finalists is in the
running to design a permanent
monument in ottawa something the
government says will recognize the
commitment and sacrifice of those who
served
and those who supported them for
architects and artists
striking the right tone is a challenge
we just tried to put ourselves in the
position of the families
that would visit this place and felt
like
deeply connected to their experience
some veterans and military historians
are conflicted
about the best way to remember a war in
which the overall number of canadians
killed
165 was far lower than the two world
wars or the korean war
on the other hand the afghan mission has
been credited with reviving interest in
remembrance day ceremonies
and it's had a big impact for many
canadians it may have something to
do with the increased interest by the
general public
in what was happening in afghanistan i
mean you can remember
the television the televised ramp
ceremonies
in kandahar in trenton the highway of
heroes and the people that were lining
it
the government says the panel appointed
to select a winning design will consider
survey submissions from canadians before
announcing a winner later this year
the monument is expected to be completed
and installed by 2024
ross lord global news
up next meet the man who lived to tell
the tale
of being eaten by a whale
we could try to avoid cliches with
tonight's final story
but it really is a whale of a tale a
commercial lobster diver in cape cod
massachusetts is recovering at home
tonight
after a fluke encounter with a humpback
whale
he says he was scooped up and nearly
swallowed but as mike armstrong
explains he was spit out instead
this is michael packard arriving home to
a family
in shock the smile he's wearing washes
away
when he tells the story of his close
call and what went through his mind
this is how you're going to go michael
this is how you're going to die in the
mouth of a whale
packard was in the water friday morning
off the tip of cape cod
he was diving fishing for lobster in the
past he's had some encounters with great
white sharks
there is danger in the job when i kiss
him goodbye in the morning i
i it's not a day that doesn't go by that
i don't think about him
and what he does now no one thought one
of these would be a problem a humpback
whale
packard says he never saw it coming felt
a bump and
everything turned dark then he realized
where he was
whale's mouth and he's trying to swallow
me
and i thought to myself okay this is it
well the whale wasn't too happy about
the situation either and packard says
after about 30 seconds
he was basically spit out i couldn't
believe it
i couldn't believe i got out of that
[Music]
incidents with whales happen but rarely
they're usually just kayakers getting a
little too close
he knocked it over there was a case in
november in california where a kayaker
ended up for a moment
in a mouth this is how it looked for
that kayaker
marine biologist dr ian kerr says whales
aren't that interested in humans
in 30 years he says he's heard of a
story like packard's twice
it was likely he says just an accident
the whale does not
does not want a human desert he just
happened to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time
well the whale seems to have left
unharmed leaving packard with some bumps
and bruises
and a heck of a fishing story about the
one that got away because
he's the one that got away mike
armstrong global news
the whale didn't want him for dessert
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is saskatoon
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend
have a great night
you